red light blue light and green light
combined to make light with no color
it's white adding three things together
that cancel out to nothing is pretty
rare in fact I can't think of any other
examples off the top of my head
inside a proton there are three smaller
particles called quarks quantum
mechanics says that identical quarks
can't exist in the same place so
physicists new quarks must have some
secret property that when three add
together the property cancels out
because protons with three quarks don't
possess that property they called it
color charge and quarks come in red blue
and green even though it has nothing to
do with actual visual colors that's been
a little confusing can you think of
anything else that adds in three to
cancel out
so maybe that would be a better analogy
than color